We went with a lookalike
because there are actual replicas.
People have built very close-to-scale
replicas of a 1911, 1910 Wright Flyer,
but they found the same problems
the Wrights did.
The airplane isn't exactly
what you call reliable.
Very often, it crashed.
And frankly, we don't want to have
to fix our airplane after every flight.
We don't like the “crash” word.
So we built out of modern materials
with modern building techniques,
so that we could fly on a frequent basis.
We'd like to be able to land the airplane
and put somebody else on it
and continue flying.
The airplane is very, very close to what
a 1911 Wright B Flyer would have looked like.
Once you get 100, 200 feet away from it,
if we overfly people,
a 1911 Wright Flyer is what you see.
We're trying to recreate
what people in 1911 Dayton, Ohio,
would have seen if Orville or Wilbur
had flown over top of them.
And when you're inside the airplane,
this is not an open cockpit airplane.
This is a no cockpit airplane.
You are literally sitting in front of
the wing, and experiencing flight
the way that people did
at the early turn of the century.
The Wrights knew that in order to roll the airplane,
they had to change the lift of each wing.
They literally just twisted the wings.
The wood would bend inside the airplane.
They had a small tray that they sat on,
and when they shifted their body,
there were wires that were hooked
to the ends of the wing,
and that would twist each wing
in opposite directions
to be able to give them
that lift differential.
The replicas that have flown
have done that.
It's incredibly difficult
to be able to control.
So to be able to get something
where you can
safely and repeatedly do that
is very, very, very challenging.
And that's why we went with the ailerons.
The Wrights actually started out
as bicycle engineers, if you will.
They were bicycle mechanics.
So they were very familiar with chains.
And when they realized
they could only have one engine,
but they needed two propellers to generate
the thrust that they needed
to overcome the weight,
they very quickly realized a single chain
going to each propeller,
one of them is inverted so that
you have counter-rotating propellers,
was the way to do it.
So we've done the same thing
on our airplane.
We have one engine, and we have
two propellers that are driven
by, frankly, a very, very,
very strong and very industrial chain.
Yes, it looks like a bicycle chain,
but when you get up close to it,
we've got a pretty solid chain
on this airplane for very good reasons.
We have a Lycoming IO390,
probably the largest four cylinder
general-aviation engine
that we could get to put on the airplane.
So rated at 210 horsepower.
The Wrights had anywhere
from 32 to around 40 horsepower,
but sometimes you got a little less,
sometimes you got a little more
because they were all hand-built.
It actually flies much like any other conventional
general-aviation airplane,
except for the fact that you're not sitting
inside of the airplane when you fly.
You and I are both part
of the drag equation of this airplane.
You are impacting the drag of the airplane
when you stick your hand out and wave.
She's got a personality to her.
And that's why we're required
to go through the flight test process,
because the FAA knows
the airplane is going to
have a personality.
The FAA has a very rigorous process
when you're building even
an experimental airplane.
We loaded the wings down with salt bags
to simulate the load of 3½ Gs.
So the airplane, we know can pull 3½ Gs.
You're never going to see 3½ Gs
in this airplane.
We've been up to
maybe 1.2 Gs in a 30° bank turn,
and that's about as steep
as we're going to go,
because we don't need
to do anything more than that.
So maybe we overengineered the airplane.
But, you know, to me, when I'm flying it,
that's the kind of stuff I'm
really interested in having underneath me.
We get a lot of head turning,
we get a lot of waves as we go by.
We're trying to preserve
early aviation history.
I've been airborne and I've looked down
and there's another airplane
flying underneath of me.
And that's just a view that you don't get
from many other airplanes.
Our original airplane,
we call the Brown Bird.
It first flew in 1982.
It has flown over 5100 passengers
over the years.
Really fun to fly.
But we're going with something now
that's a little bit more advanced,
a little bit easier to move around.
A lot of people that have
come out over the years
have said, “hey, I'm a pilot,
I've got years of experience.
“I would really like to fly your airplane”.
And we don't let other people
fly the airplane.
And it's very difficult
to fly the airplane.
We did make an exception once,
about 15 years ago.
We took a look at his credentials
and we thought, okay, you know what?
We're going to give this
gentleman a chance.
And it was impressive
how well he could control the airplane.
His name happened to be
Neil Armstrong.
So we've told other people,
if you’ve walked on the moon,
we’ll probably let you
come fly our airplane.
But until then, you know,
we're just going to
take you for a ride
when we take you flying.